mike wolfe was living his dream life as
a bicycle salesman until a catastrophic
fire destroyed his business forcing him
to start over from scratch in a new
career as a picker
being the american picker isn't the only
thing mike wolff has a knack for did you
know he's obsessed with bikes took a
stab at acting and what actually made
him start his picking business stay
tuned to find out growing up as a poor
kid in bettendorf iowa and later
leclaire wolfe had his share of bullies
to avoid them on the way to and from
school he got into the habit of cutting
through backyards and back alleys where
the only unpleasantness that awaited him
was trash
after a while the youngster started to
find out that some of this trash wasn't
so unpleasant in fact it could be
downright intriguing he told the des
moines register
the alleys were safe places for me and
that's where the garbage was too and so
the garbage became my toys and they
became part of my imagination and they
became part of who i was
according to woof his first major pick
was a discarded bike that he found in a
trash heap when he was six he told cbs i
thought to myself
if someone would throw out a bike
what else
would they throw out
even as a kid wolf felt the need for
speed in 2011 he told bicycling magazine
those big fat kids who were six years
older than me i smoked those guys on a
bike no one could touch me
as a young man he parlayed that
particular quality into a job as a
bicycle messenger in chicago for a short
time but his home state not to mention
his girlfriend at the time called him
home
he added i interviewed with bike and
hike in davenport i just told the owner
that i loved bicycles that they're my
whole life and he gave me a job building
bicycles in his warehouse
wolff admits that paying the bills was
still a bit rough at this point due to
the fact that he couldn't stop blowing
his paychecks on more bikes this however
ended up being a deceptively wise
strategy when a local shop came up for
sale wolf reminisce to bicycling
magazine i traded my old bicycles and
everything i had everything to get it i
did 150 the first day and took the store
from 75 bikes a year to 500 bikes a year
the first year that's when mountain
bikes were taking off i was the largest
manito dealer in the country it was nuts
we were rocking it so hard we opened
another store in east davenport
of course wolff wasn't just selling
bikes during this time he was also
riding them during the late 80s and into
the 90s he was a five-time competitor in
register's annual great bicycle ride
across iowa which is exactly what it
sounds like it's a grueling six-day ride
across the entire state in which
participants must complete a
jaw-dropping 67 miles per day 468 miles
in total i was riding around on european
racing bikes and not a lot of people
understood that such was his prowess as
a cyclist that he was able to bring home
a trophy or two finishing first in the
iowa state time trial championships in
1998 while he still harbored a love for
picking he was at this point living his
dream wolf was eating breathing and
sleeping bicycles while having a great
deal of personal and professional
success in the process but then fate
intervened
wolf's life changed suddenly when a
devastating fire destroyed one of his
bike stores even worse his insurance
turned out to be more of a liability
than a help he told bicycling
my shop in eldridge burned down there
was a fire in the apartment above me and
it all collapsed down into my store
the dip i bought the shop from had gone
on to sell insurance and sold me some
crappy commercial policy it took me
three years to get any money he said
that even though his bikes were still
selling it wasn't enough adding
i could never recover financially even
though the second shop was doing well i
could never get back what i lost i was
always behind then cha-ching ebay came
along and that changed my life forever
the rise of ebay meant that wolff
suddenly had a way to make money off of
his other lifelong love picking
he ultimately closed his stores bought a
van and in 2000 hit the road for the
life of a picker he confessed to
bicycling
if you would have told me that i would
close my shop back when i was selling
400 bikes a year i would have said no
way i'll be doing this forever it was my
lifelong dream but it didn't make sense
anymore so i had a going out of business
sale got a cargo van a cell phone and a
website and started antique archaeology
for about five years wolf slowly built a
living doing essentially the same thing
he does now on american pickers driving
all over the place knocking on doors
talking to collectors scouring their
collections for anything that he might
find interesting during this time he
would often shoot selfie videos
chronicling his time on the road he
added that his friends and acquaintances
would commonly mention that his life was
so unusual it would make for a good tv
show so the idea for american pickers
was born with an unexpected inspiration
anthony bourdain
wolf said he envisioned american pickers
as being similar to bourdain's
travelogue style culinary shows but
focused on collectibles instead of food
while bourdain's shows served as a
vehicle to shine light on different
regions and cultures through the lens of
food wolf similarly hoped to explore
americana through the lens of junk after
five years of pitching this idea to any
network that would listen wolfe finally
found a receptive pair of ears and
history channel executive mary donahue
donahue told the des moines register
history channel has never been just
about the past it's also about the
present and more importantly the living
breathing exciting reminders of our past
in our present day what we really
enjoyed about the american pickers pitch
was that it was outside of the shop and
that mike and frank were traveling
through parts of america that felt
really fresh to us
the original antique archaeology store
is located in leclair and the nashville
location opened soon after american
pickers debuted finding swift's success
wolfe also owns a home in the nashville
area and as one might imagine he's a fan
of country music his fan of country jams
has led to a rather unexpected second
career in writing country music in 2011
wolfe was introduced to country music
producer brian ahern whose career
stretches all the way back to the early
60s ahearns worked with the likes of
johnny cash and glenn campbell among
others a hearn it turned out was also a
fan of american pickers and pitched a
compilation project called music to pick
by of course wolfe was into it and when
he suggested a few choice cuts by
country legend dale watson for inclusion
ahearn just went ahead and got watson on
the horn and then into his studio one
marathon songwriting session later
watson and woof had penned three new
songs for the compilation soon
thereafter wolff became a newly minted
member of the songwriters organization
bmi
once american pickers and the rest of
his endeavors were gaining steady
momentum wolff and his then wife jody
faith decided that the time was right to
become parents so in 2012 they welcomed
their daughter charlie unfortunately the
occasion was cause for apprehension as
well as joy charlie was born with a
cleft lip and palate conditions which
afflict millions of children worldwide
the condition can lead to lifelong
speech eating and psychological problems
if not treated early in life fortunately
charlie received corrective surgery
which was performed promptly and
successfully wolfe realized though that
not all parents are fortunate enough to
pay for an operation like that which is
why he sought out operation smile
operation smile is a global outreach
organization with the goal of providing
cleft lip and palate treatment for those
unable to afford or access it thanks to
wolfe's sponsorship the organization's
profile has since grown significantly
wolfe has even worked to draw others
into operation smiles orbit in 2015 he
collaborated with artist isabelle bloom
to create a series of sculptures
entitled charlie's smile to benefit the
organization
wolf's passion for restoring lost
treasures isn't just limited to
motorcycles and knickknacks he also has
a soft spot in his heart for old
buildings speaking to cbs sunday morning
in 2020 he shared that he has spent
millions buying and restoring derelict
buildings both in leclaire and columbia
tennessee as it turns out his passion to
save such pieces of history didn't
simply sprout up once he had the means
to actually fund restoration efforts
back in 2003 before american pickers was
even a gleam in his eye he ran for a
city council seat in leclaire for the
sole purpose of leading a revitalization
effort in the small town
he later added
i ran for city council because i used to
walk down these streets at night with my
dog and think about what this place
could be i tell people all the time i'm
like if you want to see small town
america if you want to see main street
get in your car and drive and go take a
trip with your family because it is
disappearing
wolf and his partners do pretty well for
themselves with american pickers however
the show and his retail locations are
far from his only source of income and
it's not just all of these savvy real
estate investments and restorations that
have yielded returns either in a 2015
conversation with fast company wolf
related a conversation with history
channel executives that was quite the
eye opener he shared
history channel said something to me
about four years ago and i'll never
forget it we're not in the mike wolfe
business we're in the american pickers
business
that woke me up i said to myself you
know that's right you are in the
american pickers business and i better
get in the mike wolfe business real fast
it's safe to say that he's had some
success at that
he began with an understanding that it
was the show that was feeding his
business not the other way around
we're on television now 20 hours a week
imagine trying to buy 20 hours a week of
television what that would cost you you
couldn't do it so for us being a small
business and having that type of
exposure is crazy
it turned out that it wasn't just the
lovingly restored antiques that
customers were buying they also loved
merch
wolff added
90 of our sales are clothing so all of a
sudden i'm in the clothing business i'm
looking at what we're making for spring
i'm looking at hard goods soft goods how
those goods are presented in my store
the function the flow the lighting how
it's focused where it's at how close it
is to the cash register
i'm constantly having meetings with my
team to know what's selling and what's
not clothing sales have been so
successful that wolf has branched out
with a new clothing line called two
lanes which offers a variety of gear
both in store and online wolf may have a
lot on his plate but if he has his way
it won't be long before you're seeing
him on your tv screen doing something
other than picking through piles of junk
for the last decade or so he's been
flirting with breaking into scripted
programming this new dive started with a
2012 pitch for a workplace comedy based
on his experiences and the day-to-day
routine at antique archaeology for a bit
of time it was in development at cbs
while that project may have fallen
through wolf's acting bug remained in
2018 wolfe appeared as himself in an
episode of the long-running procedural
ncis its plot involved the gang and ncis
recognizing a piece featured on american
pickers as a potential clue in a cold
case murder investigation since i've had
this frank and i have had some
incredible luck finding things
and i'm just not willing to break up
with that mojo yet wolf hasn't popped up
in any films or tv series since but that
doesn't mean he won't as he explained to
fast company back in 2015
do i know how to pitch a movie no i
don't i have an idea but i surround
myself with people that know how to do
it do i know how to make a house
flipping show not really but i surround
myself with people that want to do it
all my ideas are organic but they come
from the same place that my passions are
and i'm smart enough to surround myself
with people that understand how those
processes need to work we wouldn't bet
against him wolfe is nothing if not
diligent and as we've seen for many
years now he has a way of scrubbing the
rust from that old gold in a grand
fashion
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]